messieurs aujourd'hui nous sommes nous
sommes réunis pour vous présenter le
travail réalisé par la commission
d'aménagement du territoire du
développement durable don je suis le
président et sur la proposition de
loi qui vise à favoriser le réemploi de
véhicules véhicules au service des
mobilités durables et solidaires sur les
territoires déposés par notre ancien
collègue Joel Labé que que je salue et
plusieurs de ses collègues en septembre
2023 texte il a été il est inspiré d'un
article additionnel inséré par le Sénat
à l'initiative de son auteur Joë Labé
dans le cadre de l'examen du projet de
loi climat et résilience cet article
n'avait malheureusement pas survécu à la
commission mixte
paritaire le dispositif prévu par la
proposition a été légèrement retravaillé
depuis la loi climat et résilience mais
son objectif lui reste le même il s'agit
de permettre que certains des véhicules
aujourd'hui mis au rebut euh dans le
cadre dispositif de la prime à la
conversion en vue de leur destruction
soit remis à titre gracieux aux
autorités organistes et organisatrices
de la mobilité les
AOM et ce à titre volontaire afin de
leur permettre de mettre en place des
services de location location solidaire
au profit des ménages les plus fragiles
4 ans après la promulgation de la loi
des mobilit
qui avait entendu renforcer le droit à
la mobilité force de constater que
l'accès à cette mobilité n'est pas une
réulité pour tous nos concitoyens en
particulier nos concitoyens dans les
zones rurales étant moi-même dans un
département très rural j'ai je le
constate régulièrement or la mobilité et
ben c'est un élément essentiel élément
essentiel pour accéder à l'emploi
élément essentiel pour accéder à
l'éducation aussi au service de santé et
un ensemble indispensable de service à
la vie quotidienne de nos concitoyens
qui n'ont pas dans nos territoires r je
le répète d'autres moyens de se déplacer
qu'avec un véhicule naturellement cette
proposition de loi n'a pas vocation
apporter une
solution au plus de 13 millions de
Français qui sont touchés par le
phénomène de précarité mobilité il me
semble toutefois que le dispositif de
loc solidaire proposé aura sa zone de
pertinence de manière tout à fait
complémentaire à d'autres politiques
publiques comme le
renforcement de l'offre de transport
collectif et le leasing social qui doit
entrer en vigueur dans les prochaines
semaine ce texte a fait et je tiens à le
saluer a fait l'objet d'un consensus
transpartisan au sein de notre
commission puisqu'il a été adopté à
l'unanimité ce et ce mercredi dernier il
y a une semaine je m'en réjouis espère
qu'il recueillera également un large
accord lors de son examen en séance
publique séance publique qui aura lieu
le 13 décembre prochain une fois adopté
par le Sénat la proposition de loi
poursuivra sa route sa route à
l'Assemblée nationale aussi nous
appelons le gouvernement à soutenir
cette initiative sénatoriale initiative
euh comme beaucoup d'initiatives
sénatoriales très pragmatiques euh qui
apportera des solutions et des solutions
concrètes concrètes à de nombreux
ménages à bas revenu ne disposant pas de
solution de mobilité voilà en préambule
ce que je souhaitais vous dire mesdames
et messieurs avant de donner la parole à
notre rapporteur Jacques
ferern merci
président bonjour à toutes et à tous euh
mesdames et messieurs les journalistes
donc je suis heureux de vous accueillir
cet après-midi pour vous présenter le
bon travail effectué par notre
commission de l'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable
donc mercredi dernier sur cette
proposition de loi Visante à favoriser
le réemploi des véhicules deux véhicules
au service des mobilités durables et
solidairire donc avant d'entrer dans le
vie du sujet donc je remercie aussi
Guillaume Gontard donc le président du
groupe écologie solidarité et territoire
pour sa présence avec nous je lui
céderai tout à l'heure la parole en tant
que Co auteur de ce texte puisqu'il
remplace son premier signataire notre
ancien collègue Joël Labé qui n'est plus
sénateur depuis octobre 2023 au cours de
mes travaux préparatoires à l'examen de
ce texte donc comme rapporteur j'ai pu
rencontrer plus d'une dizaine d'acteurs
de différents horizons en particulier
des représentants de
servicees et l'administration
centrale les collectivités locales des
représentants des garages solidaires
leurs trois principaux réseaux de garage
agile s agile ESS Solidar auto et mobine
euh mais aussi les acteurs du secteur
automobile et des associations comme le
Secours catholique très impliqué en
faveur des mobilités solidaires ces
riches échanges m'ont permis d'arriver à
un double constat que que je
qualifierais même de de paradoxe chaque
année on a des milliers de véhicules
encore en état de fonctionner qui sont
envoyés à la casse dans le cadre de la à
la conversion cela alors même qu'on a
des millions de nos concitoyens qui ne
disposent d'aucune solution de mobilité
notamment dans les territoires ruraux
donc si vous le voulez on on va
décomposer ensemble pas à pas ces deux
constats la première observation la
prime à la conversion elle favorise
c'est son but le renouvellement du parc
de véhicules au profit de véhiculle plus
récents moins pollevant ce dispositif a
été mis en place au côté d'autres aides
à l'acquisition véhiculle propre afin de
réduire l'impact environnemental et
sanitaire du secteur des transports les
transports on le sait responsable de 30
% des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
dans notre pays et d'une part importante
de polluant atmosphériques auxquels sont
associés de nombreuses pathologies parmi
ces émissions une part prépondérante
provient du transport routier et
notamment particulièrement des véhicules
individuels en pratique la prime à la
conversion elle permet aux particuliers
de se voir verser une aide qui peut
aller jusqu'à 9000 € pour acquérir un
véhicule classé critère 0 ou 1 en
échange de la mise au rebut d'un
véhicule plus polluant c'est-à-dire
classer critère 3 jusqu'à 5 ou non
classé concrètement le véhicule ancien
doit être mis à un centre de traitement
de véhicules hors d'usage on appelle les
centres VHU C centes sont agréé qui
réalisent ensuite des opérations de
dépollution de démontage du véhicule
avant de confier ce qu'il en reste
c'est-à-dire la carcasse à un broyeur la
prime à la conversion elle présente sans
conteste des résultats positif selon un
rapport du commissariat général au
développement durable c'est pour l'année
2021 45 tonnes d'émission de particules
fines qui ont pu être évité et 160000
tonnes d'émission de CO2 donc évité en
2021 grâce au dispositif de la prime à
la conversion toutefois il ressort de
mes travaux
qu'un certain nombre de véhicules
envoyés chaque année à la casse via la
prime à la conversion sont sont encore
en état de fonctionner et ne sont pas
parmi les plus polements ainsi on a 59 %
des véhicules mis au rebut dans le cadre
de ce dispositif en 2022 qui était
classé critère
3 on peut faire l'exercice de mettre ce
chiffre en regard avec la composition du
parc national donc bien plus volumineux
que les véhicules qui passent par la PR
à la conversion au sein duquel les
véhicules classés critères 3 à 5
représentent plus du tiers des véhicules
donc la destruction systématique de
l'ensemble de ces véhicules ne va pas de
soi y compris d'un point de vue
écologique parce qu'elle implique d'une
part un gaspillage passez-moi
l'expression de matériaux et de
véhicules dont dont certains ne comptent
pourtant pas parmi les plus polements et
d'autre part elle implique une
production accrue de véhicules neufs
production dont l'empreinte
environnementale et tout sauf
négligeable donc j'en viens donc à la
deuxème observation formulée dans mon
rapport on a 13,3 millions de Français
aujourd'hui en situation de précarité
mobilité 13,3 millions et parmi ces 13,3
on en a 4 3 millions pour lesquels c'est
pire parce qu'il ne dispose d'aucune
solution de mobilité selon une enquête
récente 40 % des des ménage pardon
relevant du premier cartil de revenu
donc les plus modestes ne dispose pas
d'un véhicule 40 % par ailleurs lorsque
les ménages modestes possèdent des
véhicules ceux-ci sont en règle générale
à motorisation diesel ils sont en outre
plus anciens usagés que le reste du parc
national et donc en moyenne plus polant
donc face à ce constat au niveau local
il y a des efforts qui sont déployés
depuis de nombreuses années pour mettre
en place des services de location
solidaire de véhicules au bénéfice des
publics précaires on aurait pu
s'attendre à ce que la la loi
d'orientation des mobilités la Lom de
2029 renforce ces initiatives
puisqu'elle a confié aux autorités
organisatrices de la mobilité un rôle en
matière d'organisation de service de
mobilité solidaire et à consacré cet
objectif cette mission dans le code des
transports pourtant ces démarches au au
cœur desquelles on trouve bien souvent
les garage solidaire semble se heurter à
plusieurs difficultés premièrement elle
se développe sans sans disposer d'un
cadre législatif précis sur lequel
s'appuyer s'il est bien sûr souhaitable
que les dispositifs de mobilité
solidaire tiennent compte des
spécificités de chaque territoire le
législateur a un rôle à jouer pour
soutenir faciliter et organiser ses
initiative au Sénat chambre des
territoires on le sait bien deuxièmement
le modèle économique des services de
mobilité solidaire est particulièrement
fragile contte tenu de la nécessaire
modicité des prix pratiqués à la
location qui sont généralement de
quelques dizaines d'euros par mois en
pratique les garages solidaires
dépendent donc en grande partie des dons
de véhicules effectués par les
particuliers les entreprises et les
collectivités territoriales or on
constate une raréfaction de ces dons de
véhicules au bénéfice des garages
solidaires sous l'effet de la mise en
œuvre de la prime à la conversion et
sans doute sous l'effet aussi du
développement de nombreuses offres de
leasing et donc quand vous êtes êtes
loueur de votre véhicule vous pouvez pas
le donner par définition j'ajoute que
les flottes de location solidaire dont
disposent les garages sont pour la
majeure partie constitué de véhicules
anciens diesel classé critère 4 ou 5
renouveler leur parc de véhicules
présente donc un intérêt majeur en
résumé nous avons d'un côté des services
de de mobilité solidaire dont l'activité
peut-être entravée par un gisement
insuffisant de véhicules récents et de
l'autre côté on a des véhicules
relativement récents en bon état de
fonctionnement qui sont détruits chaque
année alors que leur durée de vie
pourrait être prolongé sous réserve bien
sûr de respecter des seuils de pollution
la proposition de loi vise à faire le
lien entre ces deux problématiques en
permettant aux AOM aux AOM volontaires
de récupérer à titre gratuit les
véhicules les moins polluants parmi ceux
destinés à la destruction dans le cadre
de la prime à la conversion dans
l'objectif de déployer des services de
mobilité solidaire à destination des
ménages précaires si les bénéfices
sociaux attendus du
dispositif font font l'unanimité ne font
l'objet d'aucun débat certains acteurs
et on les comprend s'inquièteent des
risques potentiel qu'il pourrait
entraîner ce dispositif pour
l'environnement et la qualité de l'air
pour palier cette difficulté mais aussi
pour donner toute sa portée au
dispositif proposé la commission
aménagement du territoire développement
durable a donc adopté la semaine
dernière sur ma proposition neuf
amendements également adoptés à
l'unanimité à mon initiative donc
suivant deux axes et neuf amendement que
je vais vous exposer brièvement le
premier axe qui av qui a guidé le
travail de la commission il vise à
encadrer le dispositif de manière à
tenir compte des impératifs de
décarbonation du secteur du transport
parmi les adoptants parmi les
amendements pardon adoptés par la
commission sur ce point le plus
important le plus emblématique et sans
doute celui qui vise à restreindre
l'application du dispositif au seul
véhicule à motorisation
essence classé critère 3 cette évolution
est pragmatique car ces véhicules
représentent une part non négligeable de
ceux envoyés à la casse chaque année
dans le cadre de la prime à la
conversion elle permet en outre de ne
pas allonger la durée de vie des
véhicules les plus pollants d'autres
compléments judicieux ont été apportés
en commission en particulier pour réseré
à l'autorité organisatrice de mobilité
la propriété des véhicules qui seront
utilisés par des services de mobilité
solidaire en application de la
proposition de loi ceci très important
ça permet de garantir leur
traçabilité le deuxème axe ayant guidé
nos travaux vise à garantir le caractère
opérationnel du dispositif je citerai en
particulier une évolution intervenue en
commission pour faciliter la mise en
œuvre du dispositif nous avons prévu la
conclusion de convention locales entre
d'une part les AOM et d'autre part les
département il peut y avoir plusieurs
départements si c'est la région AOM qui
met en place le service de mobilité
solidaire avec d'autres AOM du périmètre
de la région AOM département association
d'utilité
publi opérateur du du du du service de
mobilité solidaire concessionnaire
automobile et le cas échéant les centres
VHU volontaires afin de clarifier les
responsabilités de chacun donc je vais
pas être plus long je vous renvoie vous
l'avez dans vos documents vos dossiers
de presse l'essentiel qui porte bien son
nom parce que vous y trouvez l'essentiel
et le détail des amendements et les
éléments principaux du rapport qui est
beaucoup plus long que l'intervention
que je je viens de faire
euh vous l'aurez compris le texte adopté
par la commission il est équilibré il
est pragmatique il permettra c'est
vraiment son ambition des avancées
concrètes pour nombre de nos concitoyens
je vous remercie de votre attention et
je cède la parole à Guillaume
[Applaudissements]
gantard merci merci
Jacques d'abord saluer le président
longjau et remercier aussi par
l'excellent travail qui a été fait par
la la commission de l'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable
et l'excellent rapporteur Jacques
fernque parce que c'est vrai que ça a
été bien
expliqué ce texte a été modifié suite
aux différentes auditions on a essayé
enfin ils ont essayé de de répondre au
au critiques au aux propositions qui
avaient pu être pu être fait donc c'est
un texte qui s'est particulièrement
enrichi au passage de la de la
commission avec le travail de la
commission et puis du coup qui a pu être
voté à l'unanimité donc c'est plutôt de
très bonne augure pour le 13 décembre
puisque le 13 décembre nous présenterons
ce ce texte dans l'hémicycle pour qu'il
soit voté par l'ensemble des groupes en
tout cas on l'espère on l'espère
fortement et puis ensuite qui puisse se
poursuivre à l'Assemblée nationale donc
on sait qu'on on essayera notamment nous
avec le groupe écologiste qui puisse
être pris à travers une niche ou comme
si c'est un texte aussi qui fait
l'unanimité pour pas pourquoi pas qu'il
trouve aussi une une place directement
dans les dans les dans les différents
enfin les planning de l'assemblée de
l'Assemblée nationale non moi je voulais
revenir parce que
Jacques a déjà très décrit en tout cas
tout ce qui était cette cette PPL et
puis le le détail mais mais revenir sur
plus sur la la genèse en fait de ce de
ce texte le le pourquoi le pourquoi de
de ce texte et ce texte qui qui me tient
particulièrement à cœur moi en tant que
président du groupe du groupe écologiste
parce que ça a été dit Joë Labé qui est
un notre ancien ancien collègue qui
avait fait deux mandat ici qui avait
beaucoup travaillé sur ces questions de
sur ces questions de mobilité euh et
puis en fait en en discutant tout
simplement avec son son garagiste parce
que c'est ça aussi c'est l'écologie de
terrain en fait celle qu'on aime bien de
de bah de de discuter et puis et puis
parfois d'avoir ces remontées là et en
discutant avec son son garagiste qui lui
faisait part en fait de cette abération
de se dire ces voitures qui sont
apportées avec cette prime à la
conversion certaines sont en très bon
état mais voilà on signe un contrat et
on est obligé de les détruire et donc
derrière cette cette aberration de se
dire est-ce qu'il y aurait pas cette
possibilité
de pouvoir les récupérer et puis ben en
plus il y a une demande parce qu'il y a
des garages solidaires parce qu'il y a
une demande en terme de mobilité
notamment sur les territoires ruraux
péri urbain et donc voilà on avait
quelque chose qui en tout cas paraissait
assez
évident et donc bah voilà c'est tout le
le travail justement qu'on peut avoir en
tant que en tant que sénateur en tant
que parlementaire bah à travers cette
discussion à travers cette discussion de
terrain et ben travailler donc Joël
avait travaillé sur un un amendement en
2000 201 pendant la loi climat et
résilience et avait proposé cet
amendement qui avait été voté au Sénat
et puis ensuite qui avait été évacué on
va dire à l'Assemblée à l'Assemblée
nationale mais c'est déjà un amendement
qui avait fait qui avait fait débat et
c'est vrai que ça nous
avait pour le coup on s'est dit on va
pas on va pas rester là parce que ça à
l'époque ça avait déjà fait é cour vous
voyez que c'était quelque chose
d'essentiel c'était quelque chose de
pragmatique d'écologique évidemment sur
la question de la de la réutilisation et
donc de retravailler sur cette sur cette
question c'est vrai qu'à l'époque il y
avait aussi un certain nombre de
critiques de faire attention de ne pas
réutiliser des voitures qui soient
effectivement polluant qui ont le
souhait de les enlever du marché pour
les les remettre les remettre en service
donc il y avait cet encadrement dont as
parlé aussi aussi Jacques fernck et ce
travail a été fait on a décidé avec avec
Joël Labé de de relancer ça suite à
suite à cet amendement pour arriver
justement à à ce texte et puis tout le
travail qui en découle et qui et qui a
très bien décrit décrit Jacques et pour
arriver en fait ce qu'on peut appeler
aujourd'hui la VLM alors c'est pas la
voiture Labé c'est la voiture à loyer
modéré et je dirais avec avec l'option
3S seconde vie solidarité et et service
euh parce que c'est tout ce qu'il y a
dans ce dans ce texte et dans ce et dans
ce et de dans ce principe c'est-à-dire
que ça a été dit les questions à la fois
d'inclusion d'inclusion sociale toutes
ces personnes qui n'ont pas accès aux
mobilités et ça a été dit moi aussi j'ai
été maire et habite dans une commune de
de moins de 200 habitants donc je sais à
peu près ce que sont les problématiques
de de mobilité justement quand on n pas
de transport en commun quand on n' pas
d'autres alternatives alors il y a le
vélo électrique il y a l'autopartage il
y a le covoiturage il y a plein de
d'aspects comme ça sur lequel on peut
travailler sur les mobilités en zon
rurales mais là c'était une nouvelle
pierre en tout cas un élément
supplémentaire parce que en zone rurale
ben on a aussi besoin de la voiture
individuelle et la problématique c'est
qu'on a un certain nombre de personnes
qui n'ont pas accès à cette voiture
individuelle pour des raisons
financières évidemment euh d'autres qui
ont une voiture individuelle mais comme
le disait Jacques souvent qui sont
anciennes plutôt polluantes et puis
d'autres qui ont une voiture
individuelle puis qui n'ont plus les
moyens de l'entretenir qui n't plus les
moyens de faire passer le contrôle
technique et donc ben qui sont assignés
à résidence et être assigné à résidence
bah ça veut dire ne pas avoir accès à la
culture ne pas avoir accès à à la santé
ne pas avoir accès à l'ensemble des
services et c'est aussi la question du
travail on a énormément je crois que
c'est 28 % des demandeurs d'emploi qui
disent avoir renoncé à un emploi parce
que justement ils n'avait pas de de
véhicule pas de moyen de transport et
pas pas de moyen de se déplacer donc
c'est V que ce ce texte du coup répond
en partie en tout cas apporte une une
solution très très concrète et puis
surtout moi ce que je trouve ce qui est
intéressant euh c'est qu'il s'appuie sur
du réel il s'appuie sur du concret il
s'appuie sur de l'existant puisque les
garages solidaires existent ils sont
déjà en pratique on en avait visité un
certain nombre avec avec avec Joë euh et
voir le le fonctionnement donc on
s'appuie vraiment sur un réseau qui
existe et sur un réseau qui a amené
aussi à se développer et à travers ce
texte moi c'est ce que je trouve
intéressant c'est de répondre aussi à
difficulté de de ces garages solidaires
qui ont des difficultés à pouvoir
récupérer des voiture et conforter leur
flotte leur flotte des de de véhicules
euh mais c'est c'est aussi pour eux une
une possibilité de se développer et en
fait en s'appuyant sur les autorités
organisatrices des des mobilités on
espère aussi que ça permett peut-être
sous d'autres formes peut-être sur
d'autres aspects que ce ce principe de
de location solidaire se développe sur
sur l'ensemble des territoire donc c'est
aussi à
travers ce ce texte ce qu'on ce qu'on
souhaite et ce qu'on et ce qu'on espère
et puis il y a l'intérêt évidemment
environnemental
euh puisque pareil Jacques l'a bien l'a
bien précisé le fait de réutiliser et de
voilà et de redonner une seconde vie à
ces véhicules on sait très bien que si
on fait rouler une un véhicule critère 3
pendant 2 ans 3 ans supplémentaires on
sait bien qu'en impact euh en impact
carbone on est évidemment beaucoup plus
positif et en même temps on rend on rend
ses services et puis il y a quand même
un un aspect aussi dans ce texte qui
parle du rétrofit du passage aussi à à
enfin la possibilité de passage à l'
électrique et ça aussi c'est quelque
chose d'intéressant puisqu'on demande un
rapport aussi sur la question du
rétrofit parce qu'on sait que c'est
aussi quelque chose c'est aussi une
mission que pourrait avoir des garages
solidaires à pouvoir passer leur
flottees euh car abonné en flotte en
flotte électrique et là pour le coup
avoir aussi dans un second temps une
réelle réponse une réelle réponse parce
qu'on nous en parle aussi sur les ZFE et
de pouvoir aussi du coup donner cette
réponse là et toutes les questions qu'on
peut se poser sur les sur les ZFE donc
on voit aussi que c'est un texte à à
deux temps sur lequel on peut encore on
peut encore avancer voilà moi je serai
pas je serai pas plus long en tout cas
très satisfait on espère mais je j'ai
pas beaucoup de doute pour que ce texte
trouve une très grande majorité voire
l'unanimité ici ici ici au Sénat après
on espère évidemment et on fera tout
pour et on a je dirais les appuis pour
que ce ce texte ensuite soit voté à
l'Assemblée nationale le travail aussi
qui a été fait à la fois par le
rapporteur et par la la commission
puisquil y avait quelques réticenceces
auprès du gouvernement mais je pense
qu'on a pu vous avez pu en tout cas par
votre travail répondre en fait à ces
réticences donc on espère aussi que côté
gouvernement ce texte sera apprécié je
pense que c'est plutôt plutôt en bonne
voie donc voilà il plein de raisons
d'être satisfait et moi aussi c'est très
satisfait parce que je trouve que c'est
le texte je dirais emblématique en fait
de ce que peut être ben l'écologie de
terrain de ce qu'on aime faire ici ici
au Sénat c'est pratique c'est concret ça
rend service et c'est évidemment avec un
intérêt écologique important derrière
donc je dirais que voilà on espère
derrière avoir d'autres textes qui ont
cette même philosophie voilà merci
beaucoup merci Guillaume nous sommes
maintenant V disposition pour les
questions attz on va vous donner un
micro parce qu'il y a des gens qui sont
en distantiel et qui doivent entendre
aussi bonjour Antoine meant pour
l'Agence France Presse pour prolonger ce
que vient de dire Guillaume Gontard sur
les liens avec le gouvernement est-ce
que vous leur avez parler de cette
proposition qu'est-ce qu'ils ont dit
quelles étaient les réticences que le
président gontar vient d'évoquer et
qu'est-ce qui vous permet de croire
qu'il peuvent adhérer à cette
proposition de loi c'est parce que les
les réticen
du gouvernement et principalement de la
la direction générale énergie climat
c'est celle qui avait motivé le fait que
l'amendement de la lo à l'époque de la
lo climat ne passe pas cap de la CMP
c'est-à-dire je les cite le dispositif
ne compenserait pas la perte de Bénéfic
environnemental notamment dans sa
composante de réduction de la pollution
particulle F et la DGC nous disait
un dispositif qui remettrait des diesels
écartés de la circulation par le biais
de la prime à la
conversion ça signifierait qu'on
perdrait 75 % des gains en réduction de
CO2 issu de la prime à la conversion 80
% des gains réduction en dioxyde d'azote
et la quasi totalité des gains en
particules fin c'est ce que disait la
dJC on l'entend et donc le la
rectification opérée par la commission
elle a justement été faite pour répondre
à cet argument majeur en écartant les
diesels en écartant les critères 5 les
critères 4 en gardant les critères 3 euh
alors on avait imaginé un instant et
c'est ce que disait la première
proposition c'est que les critères
d'éligibilité des véhicules en gros le
Tami par lequel on passe les véhicules
de la prime à la conversion pour savoir
lesquels on peut garder soit travaillé
grâce à laadem laadem nous a dit
aujourd'hui dans l'état des possibilités
technologiques il n'est pas possible de
se baser sur l'état réel d'émission du
véhicule de chaque véhicule euh pour
faire le tri c'est pas possible
aujourd'hui on a le contrôle technique
quel qui fonctionne pour arriver à du
contrôle technique en situation de
rouage de roulage réel je va y arrié euh
ça serait trop coûteux c'est pas encore
au point ça sera peut-être au point plus
tard donc la seule façon de de faire de
faire le critère c'est euh les
caractéristiques de sortie d'usine
c'est-à-dire critère 1 2 3 4 et non
classé ou la motorisation et donc ce
qu'on a fait c'est qu'on s'est basé sur
ces critères critères 3 et uniquement
essence donc on espère que de ce point
de vue-là c'est une nouvelle donne qui
euh va permettre à la DGC au
gouvernement euh de voir avec un nouveau
regard cette proposition de loi sinon le
gouvernement nous a pas caché que la
partie les perspectives avec le
développement possible du réofit ça ça
l'intéressait bien sinon on a croisé en
off en off parce que je suis pas sans
porte-parole on a croisé tout à l'heure
Clément B en salle des conférences avec
avec ce des garages solidaires qui nous
a dit ça devrait bien se passer voilà
mais bon je pass en
porte-parole
oui excusez-moi Jean-Philippe Arou la
lre de l'environnement local une petite
question enfin plutôt une interrogation
sur l'impact financier pourra avoir
votre proposition de loi sur les les les
collectivités territoriales parce qu' il
me semble que indirectement elle
pourrait être de nature à aggraver la
situation financière dans une certaine
mesure des collectivités territoriales
qui n'est déjà pas fameuse aujourd'hui
je m'explique la loi l'omme a imposé aux
collectivités territoriales un cô tas de
renouvellement de
véhicules comme étant des véhicules à
faible émission qui sont des véhicules
qui sont évidemment très efficients d'un
point de vue écologique mais qui coûtent
plus cher donc ça ça fait à la fois le
bonheur et le malheur des
collectivités vous avez pris une mesure
pour la traçabilité qu'on comprend très
bien qui consiste à dire que les
véhicules seront acquis par les
collectivités locales donc ces véhicules
vont être comptés dans leur parc et ils
vont donc s'intégrer dans la base qui
sert au calcul du côat de renouvellement
des véhicules à
faible émission autrement dit ils vont
augmenter le volume des véhicules à
faible émission que les collectivités
devront racheter en respectant leurs
échéances par rapport au aux échéances
de renouvellement qui sont prévu par la
Lom si vous voyez où je veux en venir et
donc ça va leur coûter plus cher pour
celles qui sont volontaes parce que vous
leur laissez le choix je comprends bien
je vois vous voulez en venir et et on n
pas fini à mon avis d'amender ce texte
hein il passe la semaine
prochaine en dans l'hémicycle et
effectivement c'est un point si on
compte ces véhicules dans le périmètre
total du parc c'est bien ça votre
question de la collectivité et que les
obligations de renouvellement
comprennent ces véhicules donc il faut
effectivement réfléchir cette question
sinon sur le coût pour la collectivité
de la mise en place du
dispositif c'est aussi une question qui
peut se poser hein car ces véhicules il
y a des contrôles techniques à faire il
faudra bien les assurer il y a des des
des coup de mise en place du dispositif
il y a quand même du travail humain euh
et et c'est bien pour ça d'abord les
collectivités seront volontaires c'est à
elle de choisir ce qu'elles veulent
faire et on
on on a bien en tête la subsidiarité
nécessaire c'est-à-dire que il y a toute
une part qui relèvera de la convention
que chaque collectivité mettra en place
avec les parties prenantes qui permettra
de de de bien voir les difficultés les
problèmes de voir quelles sont les
responsabilités les uns et aux autres
comment sont assurés les les les
finances indispensable il y en aura un
petit peu pour la mise en place de
dispositif voilà sinon j'entends bien
votre remarque sur les obligations de
renouvellement et qui serait dommage
effectivement d'aggraver de charger la
barque de collectivité volontaire pour
des services de solidarité indispensable
et qui ont aussi le le souci de de de
respecter les les obligations de
renouvellement de leur parc de véhicules
ce qui est bien normal et moi
j'ajouteraiis simplement à ce que disait
Jacques tout à l'heure c'est que ça ça
un objectif aussi l'objectif c'est quand
même de permettre à celles et ceux qui
aujourd'hui n'ont pas les moyens de se
déplacer n'ont pas les moyens de d'aller
retrouver un emploi n'ont pas les moyens
de retravailler de peut-être grâce à ce
ce dispositif retrouver demain une
activité sortir du système dans lequel
il se trouve actuellement et ce qui
permettrait sans doute peut-être pour un
certain nombre de sortir du dispositif
et donc notamment pour pour les
départements hein dans le casadre du RM
RSA euh de de sortir du du tout
doucement du du dispositif grâce à grâce
effectivement à à ce ce moyen d'aller
travailler dans nos territoires ruraux
parce qu'aujourd'hui on il y a quand
même de l'activité assez forte enfin
dans mon département il y a de
l'activité assez forte mais
effectivement et beaucoup d'entreprises
nous disent mais la problématique c'est
pour un certain nombre de gens euh parce
que on a bien mis quelques transports en
commun qui moi je connais une grosse
entreprise euh où des gens viennent de
travailler de d'ornant de Mèch de
Morteau de valdon
et ils ont pas de moyen d'y aller euh
bon voilà c'est c'est donc peut-être que
derrière ça permettra quand même de de
de sortir un certain nombre de gens de
la situation dans dans laquel il se
trouent et de les remettre sur le
dispositif du travail
voilà deux petite
question comme à qui précisément ça
serait destiné est-ce que c'est c'est
les garages solidaires qui fixent les
conditions de précarité entre guillemets
des des gens à qui ça pourrait
bénéficier et autre question est-ce que
vous mettez une une barre une barrière
législative pour dire jusqu'à combien de
temps ces véhicules critère 3 maximum
peuvent être dans ce dispositif avant de
devenir trop polluant et donc de devoir
être mis à la
casse alors sur les les
les publics bénéficiaires de de ces
dispositifs donc le
texte donc prévoit qu'il y ait un seuil
d'éligibilité qui soit fixé donc là ça
sera un décret qui qui s'en chargera
euh passer par les dispositifs
associatifs ayant la pratique le
savoir-faire le savoir-être aussi
surtout du travail d'accompagnement avec
les les personnes en difficulté de de
mobilité et en difficulté sociale c'est
aussi permettre que c ces questions là
se solutionnent pas simplement par
l'application mécanique d'une grille
mais il y a tout un un accompagnement un
travail de réflexion de conseil en
mobilité pour qu'on ait des des des des
solution adapté personnalisé c'est c'est
comme ça que travaillent aujourd'hui les
garages solidaires la de garage
solidairire il y a justement ils ont ils
ont tout un
travail de mutualisation c'est pour ça
qu'ils ont des réseaux hein c'est pour
ça qu'ils ont des réseaux parce que
voilà il faut il y a du partage
d'expérience pour construire vraiment
des des des solutions adaptées et et et
des solutions qui soi autant je veux
dire pour le le leasing social par
exemple dont on en
parle là les critères on les connaîtra
les les modalités les les temps
d'attente pour attendre le véhicule qui
arrivera et cetera là il s'agit de de de
de situation d'urgence hein c'est un
intérim que je vais refuser ou non c'est
une solution d'insertion dans la vie
professionnelle pour un jeune qui se
présente mais qui nécessite des
solutions de mobilité et donc qui
demande vraiment du du rapide du couu du
cou humain euh et et et et c'est dans
cette cette ces ciblesl que vise le
dispositif sur le la durée de de vie des
véhicules sur la durée de vie donc le le
le le décret donc déjà dans le texte de
loi
euh il est prévu donc queil y ait un un
il est prévu que donc il y a une durée
de vie en tant qu'utilisation dans le
cadre du service solidaire qui soit
limité hein on les leur statut de ces
véhicules qui ne sont pas des déchets
mais qui auraient dû l'être parce qu'ils
sont passés par la prère conversion donc
il a une espèce de de de de de
trouvaille juridique dans un des
articles au début de notre texte qui
permet de les sortir temporairement on
les suspend en quelque sorte ils sont
voués à devenir des déchets et à finir
par être détruits mais pendant un
certain temps qui sera limité et le
moyen justement c'est pour ça qu'il est
important que laaom soit propriétaire du
véhicule c'est qu'on a le rendez-vous du
contrôle technique auquel tout le monde
est exposé tous les 2 ans et un véhicule
qui n'est pas dans les clous du contrôle
technique c'est un véhicule qui n'est
plus en règles donc si un de ces
véhicules par je ne sais quel
cheminement se retrouve hors des règles
B il sera autant dans l'illégalité que
n'importe quel véhicule qui a pas le
contrôle technique donc ça permet que
cette nécessité d'éviter de
de laisser circuler librement pour une
durée
indéterminée des
véhicules non c'est pas possible parce
que c'est la om qui est propriétaire et
c'est elle qui en tout cas à l'échéance
du contrôle technique a les moyens de
dire si on continue ou
non on a plusieurs questions en
visio monsieur riposo peut-être en
premier puis Jérémy Morau Éric bergerol
et Florence gunalc
allezy on ne vous entend pas oui si vous
pouvez activer
voilà je viens d'avoir réponse à ma
question qui était
effectiv je viens d'avoir réponse à ma
question comme j'ai indiqué dans le fil
qui était uniquement sur la durée
d'utilisation de ces véhicules je viens
d'entendre la réponse donc je je retire
ma question
alors sinon si vous voulez poser votre
question par écrit je peux je peux la
lire j'avais Éric ber bergerol qui
demandait donc il écrivait je crois
comprendre que les critères 3 ainsi
repêché et sauvés de la casse ne serait
proposé qu'X AOM mais pas au garage
solidaire simples associations je sais
pas si vous avez répondu en partie oui
je je peux préciser oui c'est les AOM
volontaire qui deviennent propriétaires
des véhicules et euh elles ont les la
possibilité donc de passer comme
interface avec les publics bénéficiaires
par les garages solidaire par des
associations d'utilité sociale
voilà Monsieur Morau
peut-être ben maintenant ils sont
timides voilà allô vous
m'entendez prendre une question est-ce
que vous m'entendez allez-y on vous
écoute on vous écoute pendant ce temps
ils écrivent leurs questions rosamélie
bessel de Public Sénat du coup ma
question est portée sur votre article 2
qui prévoit de demander un rapport au
gouvernement sur le rettrofit et
j'aimerais bien avoir des précisions un
peu sur les objectifs de ce rapport bah
le l'article
2 pourquoi un rapport le Sénat n'aime
pas les rapports on connaît l'ancienne
qui revient euh bah c'est parce que
c'est parce qu'aujourd'hui donc il y a
un plan national depuis avril 2023 le
rétrofit c'est une grande promesse mais
c'est c'est c'est pas évident c'est pas
facile à mettre en place à déployer il y
a une question d'homologation il y a une
question aussi de coût or là on parle de
véhicules qui ont une valeur d'usage de
l'ordre de 1000 2000 3000 € he c'est cet
ordro là euh le coût du
rétrofit les auditions on a entendu des
choses de l'ordre de 10000 15000 € voilà
euh je vais d'ailleurs visiter demain à
quand l'entreprise lor l'or auto lor
moto l'or moto mais qui fait pas des
motos qui fait des autos voilà à qu qui
fait du rétrofit de twingo 1 donc je
vais je vais voir ça mais en gros
euh pour l'instant c'est l'ADEM qui nous
le dit euh le rétrofit appliqué au
véhicules particuli les modèles
populaires hein pas des des SUV euh il y
a aujourd'hui on bute encore sur un
problème de bilan économique
c'est-à-dire que c'est c'est coûteux et
donc ça ne semble pas réaliste de façon
massifiée pour l'instant d'où l'intérêt
de ce de ce rapport à venir parce qu'il
nous permettra de voir comment les
possibilités du rétrofit peuvent être
exploité être travailler dans l'intérêt
aussi de la mobilité solidaire donc des
des public des catégories plutôt précair
en difficulté de mobilité dans les zones
rurales
principalement si alors il reste une
question Jérémy Morau pour
M6 reconditionner en quelque sorte des
véhicules critère 3 peut aller à contre
peut aller contre la volonté du
verdissement du parc automobile j'ai
bien compris pourquoi avoir choisi les
essences et pas les diesel mais quel
impact du coup sur
l'environnement alors
euh au vu de ce qu'on a entendu en
audition je le citais tout à l'heure
l'avis de la DGEC euh c'était surtout
euh les diesels qu'il fallait par
remettre dans la circulation
euh oui les critères 3 donc il faut
tenir compte du fait que des critères 3
45 c'est 32 % c'est un bon tiers du parc
en circulation réelle aujourd'hui
euh si euh
si vous voulez c'est c'est ce que disait
tout à l'heure je crois je crois
Guillaume
euh ces véhicules il y a un impact
environnemental il y a une empreinte
c'est de la matière c'est de la
technologie tout cela on l'a investi
dans dans ce
véhicule lui faire cesser sa sa vie et
donc le bon usage qu'il peut faire pour
rendre des service de mobilité de façon
prématurée donc c'est un choix si on
estime qu'il est trop polement euh si on
considère que ben on en a parlé donc les
les publics considérés utilisent
aujourd'hui donc soit ils sont en panne
de mobilité soit ils utilisent euh des
véhicules bien plus polluants que les
critères 3 euh globalement du point de
vue environnemental on on on fait une
affaire qui est pas mauvaise hein
d'autant qu'il y a une étude de liadri
qui nous dit clairement euh que euh
entre euh des ménag plutôt classe
moyenne aisé qui ont des habitudes de
renouvellement de leurs véhicules de
l'ordre de tous les 3 an et qui prennent
à chaque fois le le meilleur peut-être
pas le plus léger hein mais en tout cas
le meilleur du point de vue de ses
caractéristique sortiese d'usine du
point de vue de leur impact sur la
pollution donc entre cela et des gens
qui feraient durer plus longtemps des
véhiculle ancien et bien si on regarde
du point de vue du bilan environnemental
des uns et des autres et ben ceux qui
sont meilleurs pour l'environnement
c'est cela c'est ceux qui qui
utilisent sans les jeter pour prendre à
nouveau très vite des véhicules encore
en bon état de fonctionner en faisant le
choix
euh je dirais le seul possible pour
l'instant hein en fonction
des la classification critères et de la
motorisation à mon avis on on fait un
choix qui est qui est équilibré et j'ai
deux dernières questions des précisions
sur des chiffres 59 % d'automobile mis
au rebut seraiit des critères 3 combien
à votre avis sont des essences si vous
avez cette répon
et sur votre proposition de
loi les journalistes souhaiteraient
avoir une idée du nombre de véhicules
concernés par année si vous avez un
alors on a ces on a ces éléments
chiffrés al je suis pas tout à fait sûr
qu'on a le nombre de diesel parmi les
critères
3 non je je crois qu'on les a pas
eu mais sinon donc je pour répondre sur
des chiffres faut que je donne des
chiffres précis donc j'ai peur de me
tromper à
quelques ordre de grandeur
oui parler un petit peu plus
fort% une fourch évaluation donc 20 à 30
% c'est critères voilà 20 à 30 % des
critères 3 mis au rebut par le biais de
la prime à la conversion sont des
essences
voilà et sur le nombre de véhicules
concernés par votre proposition de
loiors si on prend 20 à 30%
des critères 3 alors les critères 3
représentent combien 59 % donc vous avez
20 à 30 % de 59 % sachant que le dernier
chiffre qu'on a c'est 2022 la primre la
conversion c'était 92000 véhicules je me
suis pas trompé là 92000 véhicules donc
vous prenez 59 % de 92000 et vous prenez
32 % de ça et vous voyez à peu
près les
quelques milliers dizaines de milliers
de véhicules qui pourra
concern merci je crois qu'il y a plus de
questions en visio si on en a une devant
mais c'est pas en visio va vous donner
le micro
encore merci
oui une autre question est-ce que si
j'ai bien compris les véhicules pourront
être
prélevés dans les centres
VHU alors c'est justement ça qu'il est
important qu' a une convention
travaillée sur mesure en fonction des
spécificités des possibilités du
territoire
qui soit misise en place par les
concernés parce qu'autant donc prime à
la conversion il y a des démarches
individuel ok vous allez il faut pr
conversion il faut quand même avoir le
le papier qui dit que le véhicule est
voué à la destruction donc ça c'est le
centre agréé VHU qui vous le délivre bon
une bonne part des particuliers qui
veulent profiter de la pre conversion
passe par le concessionnaire hein parce
que comme il priment la conversion ils
achètent une nouvelle voiture en même
temps donc concessionnaire s'occupe de
ça donc il est important que dans le
conventionnement euh laom pense c'est
pour ça qu'on le propose he fera ce
qu'elle veut à mettre dans la boucle les
concessionnaires certains seront plus
alant que d'autres pour les centres VHU
il est clair que les centres VHU leur
modèle
économique c'est de démonter ce qui est
démontable et réutilisable des véhicules
hein pour remettre en bonne circularité
d'économie circulaire des pièces qui
peuvent
réutiliser la carcasse broyée on
récupère des ti et cetera qui sont
recyclés donc mais c'est pas parce que
c'est peut-être pas leur intérêt
économique qu'ils vont pas le faire hein
voilà donc il faut aussi les mettre dans
la boucle du conventionnement mais c'est
clair que
euh il faut organiser les choses pour
que aussi bien les concessionnaires
puissent avoir le réflexe que les
centres VHU qu'ils souhaitent puissent
se dire c'est une possibilité et puis
une loi c'est aussi l'affaire des
citoyens hein donc d'où l'intérêt de
faire connaître le dispositif que les
gens bah voilà les dons sassèche dit-on
pour les garages solidaires ceux qui
faisaient le choix de donner des
véhicules au garages solidaire c'est
bien parce qu'ils ont un ils ont un but
une volonté de solidarité si on leur dit
très bien la prime à la conversion vous
voulez en profiter on vous comprend mais
vous avez la possibilité de passer un
petit mot à votre concessionnaire de
dire à votre centre VHU attendez moi je
suis critère 3 je suis essence il y a un
dispositif qui existe j'aimerais que mon
véhicule passe par là donc c'est c'est
c'est pour ça qu'il est important que la
loi soit aussi l'affaire des
citoyens c'est vrai que le centre VHU à
partir du moment où il a récupéré le
véhicule lui vous le disiez il il le
désosse et évidemment il en il en tire
un profit beaucoup plus important que
s'il revendait d'ailleurs le véhicule
enti votre question or ils sont en train
ces centres là ils sont relativement en
tension ces derniers temps parce qu'ils
doivent consentir des investissement
très important au nom de l'économie
circulaire c'est là où le serpent se
morort peut-être un peu la queue parce
que il faut qu'ils investissent dans des
dispositifs performants qui doivent
permettre de fournir la France entière
en pièce de réemploi puisque maintenant
quand on est un particulier qu'on va
dans son garage on peut demander on peut
même exiger de son garage d'être réparé
avec des pièces de réemploi les pièces
de réemploi on les trouve où dans les
centres VHU mais évidemment on va pas
faire la tournée des C VHU avec son vélo
avec sa voiture pour rechercher une
pièce donc on a des systèmes sur
Internet qui nécessite de la
numérisation enfin je passe là-dessus
bref ça coûte très cher et ça c'est
supporté par ces fameuses entreprises
que sont les cent VHU donc eux ils ont
plutôt besoin d'argent en ce moment
alors je sais pas s'il serait très
favorable à laisser échapper quelques
voitures on a posé la question donc on a
on a on a auditionné donc la la la
filière constructeur automobile
mobiliance le réseau dont qui qui qui
qui rassemble aussi les représentants
des centres
VHU en 2020 ils ont traité 1,3 million
de véhicules des C VHU sur ces 1,3
million il y en a que 13 % qui sont
issus de la prime à la conversion ok
donc déjà il y a une marge on vient de
voir qu'avec le texte tel qu'on l'
adapté c'était 59 % donc 32 % de 59 %
c'est l'épaisseur du trait
hein c'est pas ça qui va complètement
désorganiser leur modèle leur modèle
économique la difficulté aujourd'hui de
la la responsabilité élargie du
producteur en terme de véhicule
terrestre c'est que oui euh ça
fonctionne bien pour ce qui est
identifié ce qui est tracé ce qui est
légal mais si on regarde le nombre de
véhicules euh abandonnés en filière
illégale exporté ailleurs ou euh étant
sorti des radars sans contrôle technique
euh sans carte grise ou sans carte grise
oui euh c'est là qui est l'enjeu de la
filière REP et des centres verchu c'est
de de
réussir à ne pas se contenter d'être
performant avec les véhicules qu'on leur
amenait mais de réussir à capter c'est
la
responsabilité responsabilité élargie
des producteurs hein mais mais de capter
l'ensemble des déchets de la filière de
la filière de l'automobile et là
d'ailleurs on a
échangé avec les interlocuteurs qu'on a
eu du côté des administrations le cahier
des charges est en train d'être revu ils
ont des des objectifs qui vont leur
permettre d'avoir plus de véhicules à
traiter et à mon avis ce qu'il gagneront
de ce point de vue-là sera bien plus
important que ce qu'on leur enlèvera
avec les critères 3 essence qu'on
prolongera quelqu temps mais qui leur
arriveront quand même en bout de course
qui leur arriveront quand même en bout
de course c'est simplement un décalage
dans le temps nous notre texte il opère
une sorte de conversion dans la
conversion voilà on permet au public
précaire en difficulté d'une part ceux
qui ont des véhicules
vraiment en sale état avec des
performances environnementales médiocre
d'en avoir des meilleurs hein et ceux
qui n'ont pas de solution mobilité zone
rural et cetera bah de pouvoir sortir
cette précarité de
mobilité je crois qu'on a fait le
tour bien donc vous aurez encore des tas
de choses intéressantes le Tr décembre
dans dans l'hémicycle on aura un débat
tout à fait passionnant parce que
c'était aussi intéressant en commission
on vous dit que c'était à l'unanimité
qui a pas eu d'abstention mais c'était
aussi un débat riche danse avec beaucoup
de collègues qui sont intervenus oui
c'est pas parce que ça étéanité qui a
pas eu de question et de débat ouou
voilà
voilà bien merci